all right settle in because I'm about to
show you some cringe-worthy video clips
this week Donald Trump as you may know
visited a number of countries in the
Middle East visiting countries in Europe
landed in Brussels Belgium today Monday
and Tuesday Trump was in Jerusalem in
Israel meeting with a president Reuven
Rivlin and Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu a number of highlights and I
want to lead up to Donald Trump totally
and completely humiliating himself once
again but let's start slow I don't want
to throw everything at you at once so
Trump arrived in Israel after leaving
Saudi Arabia and he says we just got
back from the Middle East of course
Israel is in the Middle East so not
exactly starting off that visit to
Israel in a strong way then we'll get to
the video clips for our TV audience
Donald and Melania Trump were walking
with Benjamin Netanyahu and his wife who
were holding hands Donald Trump tried to
hold
milania's hand and she sort of slaps his
hand away in a very very odd way and
then Trump he was kind of smooth oh yeah
I was just trying to adjust my tie not
hold my wife's hand
she then again refused to hold Donald
Trump's hand last night when they
arrived in Rome and were getting off Air
Force One and you see Donald Trump
trying to hold her hand and Melania
pulling her hand away and moving some
hairs out of out of her eyes and then
Donald Trump instead patting her on the
buttocks so potentially trouble in
paradise is Melania Trump being held
hostage we had that viral video that got
four or five million views Pat where we
caught Melania looking very very
concerned during the inauguration and
and not pleased with Donald Trump so a
number of these lightly cringe-worthy
moments during the trip to Israel you
with me so far
yeah well it's no wonder why Melania is
staying in New York City instead of a
White House with Trump I think she found
out about all these sexual assault
allegations and the troubles in Donald
Trump's past at the same time as we did
well she says she's forgiven Donald I
mean that we should as well and I
believe her or something yeah maybe not
so let's get back to Trump's trip to
Israel okay
then at another point during his trip in
Israel Donald Trump defends himself
against an allegation about Russia that
nobody ever made he appeared alongside
the Israeli Prime
Benjamin Netanyahu and the press started
asking Trump about when he haphazardly
gave Intel to Russian diplomat in the
Oval Office information intelligence
that we now believe came from Israel and
Donald Trump basically denied something
that no one ever argued take a listen to
this so no one actually ever accused
Trump of saying hey Sergei I got this
info from Israel nobody said that Trump
told Sergei what they had learned never
mentioned it was from Israel may not
even have known it was from Israel so
again Pat Trump is denying something no
one ever accused him of there was some
speculation in the media that the
information did come from Israel but I
no one in the original source has ever
reported that Trump told the Russians
that the source is Israel absolutely and
Benjamin Netanyahu looking perplexed and
confused and sort of amused as Trump is
doing this so then here is the crowning
achievement of cringe during this trip
so far
Trump visits Yad Vashem on Mount Herzl
in Jerusalem this is Israel's official
Holocaust Memorial there's a museum the
Hall of names which remembers victims of
the Holocaust this is a very very somber
place okay and by the way I wonder what
Trump's alt-right fans think about their
Dear Leader giving a Holocaust Memorial
speech at Yad Vashem okay but who knows
what they think about that typically
when heads of state visit the site
they're asked to leave a message in the
guestbook there okay and this is where
things start to get violent humiliating
the memorial is a somber and solemn
place I've been here a somber and solemn
is is an understatement Barack Obama for
example left a pretty lengthy heartfelt
and well written note in the guestbook
when he visited in 2008 where he says
he's grateful to Yad Vashem and all of
the people all of those responsible for
it be
there as an institution he talks about a
time of great peril and strife and it's
a very well-written full page letter
typical barackobama fashion right back
when we had an intelligent and
articulate president right exactly and
he talks about let our children come
here and know the history so they can
add their voices to proclaim never again
and remember those who perished very
very nice letter that President Obama
left there george w bush okay not
exactly a ver vote verbose guy but he
left a short and solemn message when he
visited Yad Vashem
god bless israel george w bush in comes
donald trump and instead wrote in all
caps printed letters in what looks like
the writing of a little kid and i'm
going to put this note up for you it is
a great honor to be here with all of my
friends so amazing and we'll never
forget
donald trump sounds like he had a grand
old time i mean totally tone deaf as
usual it's what a second grader would
write if they were to visit Yad Vashem
and not a second grader at the top or
middle of their class this would be like
what the second grader who was out on
the day that they explained what Yad
Vashem was would write something like
this I had fun here with all my friends
in all caps it reminds me when Justin
Bieber went to the Anne Frank museum
yeah any left on it note in the
guestbook that said Anne Frank would
have been a great girl she would have
been a belieber right and that was
Justin Bieber saying that and you got a
lot of flack for it this is the
president saying that it's the President
of the United States him you humiliating
himself like he's a child and referring
only to himself and his friends rather
than to Jews Israel or the Holocaust
just embarrassment after embarrassment
today's episode of a David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses
you see which one do you like you send
them back and whichever one you pick
they will put your prescription in - I
like this because I can actually show
the glasses to other people and not have
to just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS